[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
côté mon chéri c'est vrai que 6 et en
basket la série d'émissions strictes et
pour l'instant ça fait combien de temps
qu'ils sont sur les poteaux les chéris
c'est incroyable ce qui se passe et ça
fait combien de temps qu'ils sont sur
les poteaux s'il vous plaît henry il est
derrière
attention mon cédric qu'est ce qui nous
attend ce soir à l'or la coiffure ça
vous en foutez complètement cessé je
trouve que c'est pas mal comme ça
aujourd'hui on est comme ça aujourd'hui
ça ne s'arrange pas trop ce sont dans
les lauriers je vais vous révéler qu'un
des docteurs de touche pas à mon poste
nous cache qui n'avait même pas d'être
rude
alors aujourd'hui j'étais chez le
coiffeur quoi que je sais et germain il
m'a fait remarquer une chose j'ai pas
beaucoup débriefer le prime de jeudi qui
a le meilleur client c'est vrai mais
alors petite question laquelle vous
avoir beaucoup de mal à me répondre sur
ce plateau
on a la chance d'avoir deux docteurs dix
mois mais le cousin de jason dean barker
gynéco mais un dédié pas un vrai docteur
à votre avis c'est qu'ils auront la
surface avant tout la soirée pas du test
de qi doc gynéco a eu aucune bonne
réponse
même benoît dubois magali bertin ont
fait mieux c'est dire alors je vous
remets à doc gynéco lauriers du seul
docteur où ça se voit pas du tout qui
n'a pas fait d'études on vous avez
répondu isabelle morini bosc est faible
alsace au filet 22 des lèvres du quoi
vous 4 vers des devises
il n'y a que des bonnes réponses sauf
doc gynéco l'assistante plateau qui sert
ma main porte sa montre à la main gauche
porte sa montre à la main droite porte
le montre je n'avais pas de même voir
doc gynéco verrait tous trois dont
quatre portes de mon tronc non on n'en
voit qu'une mais peut-être temps que
j'aime et que vous avez répondu quoi les
vendredis soir et comme on se demande
pourquoi donc gynéco a répondu vendredi
avec son explication c'est beaucoup plus
clair quadroni je me suis arrêté à la
première semaine
non c'est à dire de calcul vous avez
pris en compte deux semaines et à 15
secondes alors hop vendredi
l'équipe est d'ordre national gynéco
addict a bercé notre en album tha bercé
toute une génération à l'ugta bars et
même sa naissance un message commun
13ème telle quelle année c'est vanessa
j'ai rien calculer cnsl quoi c'était ok
là dit vanessa j'écris dans les oubliées
90 mois sabbatiques 4c sortie de trois
ans après parce qu'ils ont dit celui-là
ce qu'il a mis trois ans à écrire en
baisse y compris là il va faire quoi
c'est n'importe quoi ils ont réfléchi
sur 10 sortons un single
peut-être que ça va faire quelque chose
ils m'ont donné un contrat avec une
seule feuille on et chante à table je
racontais tout cas merci
mayroy quelques années après ça vendu je
ne sais combien d'albums appelé au
téléphone on m'a dit viens chercher tes
sous jeudi combien on n'est pas vos
coûts insérer quelques centimes par
album magenta d'âge tu avais écrit ouais
je crois que c'est l'internaute de
[Rires]
spécial et commercy bonne série que
cette anecdote merci et le belge va très
bien du magnifique le tee shirt avec le
costume ça sent un peu la douche c'est
hors de chez lui tous les jours il a un
nouveau métier je suis concessionnels
avec le costume c'est pas ça va les
poteaux oui la semaine dernière contre
toute attente on a découvert que gilles
verdez n'avait pas le meilleur cuit
parmi les chroniqueurs alors qu'à lui
seul il a fait plus d'études que tous
les animateurs de ces huit réunie mais
pour moi il était meilleur grâce à une
phrase sur une question de logique
évidemment même andelys maxime vignes a
répondu à côté maxime a tenté
d'expliquer sa logique mais il est tombé
sur un gilles verdez très énervé parce
que fatou venait de refuser de l'épouser
pour la 580 troisième fois jambes et
donc à gilles verdez le laurier de la
meilleure à vannes de 2019
jade est vrai sont décidés à ouvrir les
camionneurs présentateur daniela 4 après
trois et ensuite 86 l'a43 canarien que
deux fils là
[Musique]
alors si vous taclez melon sur internet
vous tombez directement sur matthieu
delormeau asm est une montagne de
muscles mais c'est pas encore une
montagne de téléspectateurs
malheureusement pour lui alors pendant
le prévenu qu on a vu que deux niveaux
réponse était pas ça mais si vous avez
fait un prime sur qui sera le plus gros
tahar bala parcours matthieu delormeau
aurait gagné parce que je remets à
matthieu delormeau
le laurier du mec qui pourrait jouer
dans mois bo et méchant smart que je me
suis dit que les deux comment dire que
ça lui mais avec un d'accord voilà vous
soucier bizarre quand un raisonnement
est idiot mais mon méchant qui s'en fout
quand sa meilleure amie lui fait une
déclaration en direct ça va magali
bertin belges aiment trop mathieu alors
juste magali bernard messassi préféré
javel morini-bosc dossier qui pourrait
même y mettre des rotours les villes
tout venant la jeanne ne doit pas les
christian c'est vrai tout çà s'appelle
et écrire c'est tout après le timing est
ainsi maintenu dans tu étais trop tard
et pour rêver on suivra aussi le buzz
à cela
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
t'es pas cap' à votre célébrité bien
cotisé ou cédric alors touche pas à mon
poste a toujours été l'émission numéro
un sur les médias et les kebabs oui mais
depuis quelques temps c'est devenu
l'émission numéro un sur la danse à
sanaa mais franchement on danse plus ici
en utilisant qu'en neuf saison de danse
avec les stars
le maire entre nous pour danser c'est
bien sûr la regarder ce petit florilège
par exemples non exhaustifs de vos
prestations
et c'est que ça dure
[Applaudissements]
l'ess
la grande salle
tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'animal est ce que tu es sexe alors ce
qui bouge je m'appelle a ému tout est
bondé
[Musique]
c'est bien frei qui était complètement
subsistent quant à lui dans ce
rassemblement comme en demandant sera en
santé sérieux ou pas alors parce que
j'ai pas danser tous les soirs tu sais
bambi je ne peux pas danser en dehors du
tatami et voilà vous demandez vous allez
voir il va danser tout de suite parce
que je me demandais comment c'était
possible devant un tel niveau de danse
c'est incroyable sans avoir pris de
court en plus à kefu may s'est bien fait
tomber tu sais ça mais alors j'ai deviné
rochelle
j'ai fait des recherches bien sûr si
vous danser si bien c'est que vous avez
participé à une saison de danse avec les
stars
sauf que tf1 nous avons deux manches
coupées au montage vous savez pourquoi
parce que vous êtes fait choper en train
de coller des cheveux sur la tête d'art
aprikian ça ne va plus du tout regardé
ça pour moi vous êtes le plus grand
danseur de toute l'histoire de dams
roboto et son partenaire l'anima
[Applaudissements]
ouais